[Music]
he's going to take off once again Tom
Cruz is shooting Top Gun three meanwhile
things are looking rather bad for Fast
and Furious 11 and Star Wars 10 get all
this information and much more now in
this week's Koch
news there's an update on the galaxy far
far away Ray actress Daisy Ridley
commented on the future of Star Wars 10
in an interview after there was some
confusion regarding the schedule of the
new films there's a lot going on in the
Star Wars Universe at the moment only
recently it was announced that a
Mandalorian movie will indeed be made
bringing the franchise back to the big
screen originally this was intended for
Star Wars 10 but the movie about Ray
Skywalker has been pushed back for the
time being following the announcement of
the Mando movie previously the film was
expected to be released in late 2025 to
Mid 2026 meanwhile a new rumor from
Insider Daniel rpk is bound to cause
some confusion according to the rumor
filming on episode 10 is set to begin in
May as planned this is also interesting
because according to the world of real
the project is currently on hold this is
probably due to creative differences
between Disney and screenwriter Steven
Knight the studio had so many requests
for changes to his draft that he
basically had to start from scratch it
is currently unclear whether he will
remain on the project or turn his
attention to the upcoming peaky blinders
movie instead he would not be the first
writer to drop out of Star Wars 10
Watchman writer Damon lindeloff and
Justin Britt Gibson had also previously
left the project ahead of time the movie
was also commented on by Daisy Ridley in
an interview with Alo C the actress
revealed that Star Wars 10 is set to
take a completely different direction
what exactly that means remains to be
seen all we know so far is that part 10
will be set 15 years after the events of
Star Wars 9 and will also focus on Ray
establishing a new Jedi Order hence the
frequently reported title Star Wars new
Jedi by order charmine obeyed chenoy who
previously directed Miss Marvel for
Disney Remains the director recently
there was controversy over an 8-year-old
clip of a panel discussion with her in
which she said she liked to make men
feel uncomfortable at the time obey
chinoi became known for her
documentaries about the violent
oppression of women in Pakistan for
which she won two Oscars critics
consider her activist background to be
incompatible with an entertainment
project like Star
Wars Sonic fans are sure to get their
money's worth in the coming years in
addition to the third installment of the
main film series and the spin-off
Knuckles Sonic's antagonist Shadow the
Hedgehog is also set to receive his own
project the iconic blue Hedgehog will be
racing across the big screen again at
the end of this year in Sonic the
Hedgehog 3 in his newest Adventure he
will then meet Shadow the Hedgehog who
was already announced in the mid- credit
scene of the predecessor Shadow is
probably one of the most popular
characters in the Sonic Universe and was
first introduced in the video game Sonic
Adventure 2 the character originated
from the shadow project which was
carried out around 50 years before the
events of Sonic the Hedgehog 2 although
Shadow often shows an arrogant attitude
he also has a more vulnerable side which
he only reveals to a few the
introduction of the character could be
the first hint that Paramount Pictures
is seemingly pursuing bigger plans these
suspicions also match the statement by
Hollywood Insider Daniel Rickman Rickman
revealed on his patreon account that
Paramount is apparently working on an
independent spin project for the
character whether this is a movie or a
series remains unclear although there
has been no official confirmation from
Paramount so far fans can look forward
to some content either way in addition
to Sonic 3 a knuckle series is also
waiting in the wings well then nothing
stands in the way of the Sonic Cinematic
Universe action fans listen up Top Gun
is getting another installment with Tom
Cruz the immense success of the sequel
top gun Maverick released in 2020 22 was
probably not expected by many the action
spectacle grossed about $1.5 billion
worldwide and was also nominated for a
total of six Oscars the movie was then
awarded in the best sound category
although the sequel was very popular
there was no talk of a possible third
part for a long time but that has
changed as deadline reports Top Gun 3 is
actually in the works at Paramount
Pictures Tom Cruz AKA Captain Pete
Maverick Mitchell will of course be
returning as will mil teller and Glenn
Powell there's no news about the return
of Jennifer Connelly and John Ham yet
based on initial information Joseph
kazinski is to take over as director
again kazinski is currently also working
on a Formula 1 film called Apex starring
Brad Pit and Javier Bardem a release
date for Top Gun 3 has not been
announced so far according to rumors
however it could be the next project for
Tom Cruz after mission impossible 8
which is currently still being filmed
we'll keep you up to date as always
attention Sports and movie fans the 58th
Super Bowl is just around the corner in
addition to the sports spectacle movie
fans can also look forward to all kinds
of trailers and teasers that'll be shown
over the course of the event the Super
Bowl is considered the world's biggest
single sport event and regularly breaks
records last year alone over 1 billion
people watched the game between the
Kansas City Chiefs and the Philadelphia
Eagles so it's no wonder that the film
industry also wants to benefit from
these immense numbers the Comm
commercial breaks during the Super Bowl
are famous for their high-profile
trailers and teasers which often
generate excitement for months in
advance last year for example we were
treated to sneak peeks of The Flash
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
and Guardians of the Galaxy 3 2024 is
likely to be even more exciting
according to the Hollywood handle we can
expect another thrilling lineup of
movies this year a first teaser for
Deadpool 3 is reportedly coming for
example the sequel starring Ryan
Reynolds and Hugh Jackman is set to be
be released in cinemas on July 26th so
the timing would be perfect in addition
to Deadpool 3 the first trailer for the
prequel a quiet place day one is also
likely to generate excitement the movie
starring Oscar winner Lupita nongo will
deal with the Alien Invasion and the
collapse of civilization new footage for
Ghostbusters Frozen Empire Godzilla X
Kong the new Empire and Inside Out 2 are
also in the pipeline we can moreover
look forward to Despicable mi4 as well
as the news from the next Garfield film
it should be mentioned that these films
are only more or less plausible
speculation for the time being it
remains to be seen which trailers will
actually be presented to us in the end
the 58th Super Bowl will take place on
February 11th of course you'll find all
the shown trailers here at Koch as soon
as they're
available there's an end in sight
according to Hollywood Insider Jeff
Snider Fast and Furious 11 will be the
last installment in the action series
the film will also come with some
changes including budget cuts and a
potential recasting of the antagonist
The Fast and Furious series was once one
of Hollywood's biggest Blockbusters
however the franchise suffered a
financial setback with fast X which
prompted those responsible at Universal
Pictures to reconsider their approach
despite a reasonable worldwide box
office result of $74 million part 10
continued the negative Trend and even
fell short of the earnings of its
predecessor Fast and Furious 9 according
to variety Universal will still be able
to make a profit but in view of the
production costs of over $340 million
this is likely to have been a small one
universal is now apparently planning to
take drastic measures to come out of the
situation with a positive result
Hollywood Insider Jeff Snyder reported
that the budget for Fast and Furious 11
is to be significantly cut this time the
limit will be $200 million although this
is still a considerable sum it is
nonetheless a significant reduction
compared to its predecessor but there
will also be some changes in terms of
content Fast and Furious 11 is allegedly
planning a return to the origins of the
series instead of global missions the
focus is now on one last Big Heist we
might even be able to look forward to
the good old quarter mile races again as
things stand at the moment it can be
assumed that the cast of Vin Diesel
Michelle Rodriguez Tyrese Gibson and
Jason Statham will return however
Universal seems to be considering
dropping Jason Mamoa from the film and
introducing a completely new villain
Mamoa meanwhile could meet Dwayne
Johnson's Luke Hobbs in an already
confirmed spin-off project the two seem
to have unfinished business
anyway playing the horror hit until dawn
in 2015 felt like a best of of its
creepy cinematic predecessors and now we
have come full circle The Hollywood
Reporter reveals that the game is now to
be made into a movie in charge are
well-known people with experience in
this genre director David S Sandberg is
leading the project he most recently
directed the two Shazam films however he
made his breakthrough with the horror
for a short film lights out which was
Then followed by a movie adaptation and
the horror sequel Annabelle 2 the final
script for the until dawn film comes
from Gary Doberman who is behind
successful films such as it as well as
Annabelle it's being based on a version
by Blair Butler who last wrote Sony's
vampire film the invitation until dawn
is about eight friends in a secluded
Mountain Lodge who experience a night of
horror involving a mysterious killer
dangerous monsters and a creepy mind it
is not known exactly how the movie
adaptation will follow the original game
however it is being described as an
R-rated love letter to the horror genre
focusing primarily on the unsel cast
while the cast has yet to be announced
the original already featured well-known
Stars such as Hayden paner and Ramy
mik and that's it for this week's Koch
Che news if you're looking to increase
your anticipation for some upcoming
releases make sure to check out our
newest trailer for the second season of
the HALO Series if you like it more
spooky instead you might enjoy the
trailer for Abigail take a look and let
us know what you think of the latest
news in the comments thanks for watching
and we'll see you next
[Music]
time